veamos la halogenación de alquenos a la
izquierda tengo mi alqueno y le agregaré
un halógeno algo como bromo o cloro y
puedo ver que esos dos átomos de
halógeno se añadirán anti uno al otro se
añadirán en lados Opuestos de donde
solía estar el doble enlace veamos el
mecanismo para que podamos saber por qué
obtenemos una adición
anti así que Empiezo con mi
alqueno aquí
abajo y mostraré el halógeno
aproximándose A ese alqueno se
aproximará de esta manera y agrego mis
pares libres de electrones
así si pienso en esa molécula de
halógeno sé que es no polar Porque si
pienso en los electrones en el enlace
entre mis dos halógenos aquí ambos
átomos de halógeno por supuesto tienen
la misma
electronegatividad ninguno está jalando
más fuerte y por lo general la molécula
es no polar sin embargo si los
electrones pi en mi alqueno diré que
estos electrones de aquí son mis
electrones pi si esos electrones se
acercan demasiado a los electrones en
azul ellos por supuesto los repeler yan
ya que los electrones se repelen el uno
al otro al ser como
Y si los electrones en magenta repelen
los electrones en azul los electrones en
azul serían forzados a estar más cerca
del halógeno de arriba así dando al
halógeno de arriba una carga parcial
negativa y dejando al halógeno de abajo
con una carga parcial positiva porque
está perdiendo un poco de densidad
electrónica ahora podría pensar en ese
halógeno de abajo actuando como un
electrófilo porque quiere electrones y
entonces en este mecanismo los
electrones pi funcionarían como
nucleófilo los electrones pi atacarán mi
electrófilo
así al mismo tiempo estos electrones de
aquí este par de electrones en el lado
izquierdo del halógeno atacará este
carbono y los electrones en azul también
se moverán a la de arriba
así continuemos dibujando el resultado
de todos esos electrones moviéndose
alrededor ahora tengo un carbono con un
enlace simple a otro carbono así los
electrones en magenta formaron un nuevo
enlace entre el carbono en la derecha y
mi halógeno así Y estos electrones de
aquí lo Resaltar en rojo este par libre
de electrones en mi halógeno formará un
enlace con el carbono en la izquierda
así y ese halógeno aún tiene dos pares
libres de electrones en él pondré esos
dos pares libres de electrones y ese
halógeno tiene una carga formal de
+1 esto es llamado ion al
cíclico y ha sido demostrado que ocurre
en este mecanismo si pienso en ese
halógeno cargado positivamente los
halógenos son muy electronegativos y
quieren electrones los electrones en
magenta digamos serán jalados un poco
más cerca a ese halógeno lo que dejaría
este carbono aquí abajo perdiendo un
poco de densidad electrónica dándole una
carga parcial positiva y entonces eso
funcionará como nuestro electrófilo en
el siguiente paso y nuestro nucleófilo
será el anón aluro creado en El Paso
anterior
cierto tuvimos un halógeno que tuvo tres
pares libres de electrones alrededor
tomó los electrones en azul Ahora tiene
cuatro pares libres de electrones ocho
electrones en total dándole una carga
formal de -1 lo que significa que ahora
puede funcionar como nucleófilo si
pienso en este ion alon cíclico de aquí
el halógeno de arriba va a prevenir que
el nucleófilo ataque desde arriba deberá
atacar desde abajo este anón aluro
cargado
negativamente atacará
nucleofílicos de aquí este carbono Y eso
mandará estos electrones en magenta a
este
halógeno continuemos dibujando los
resultados de ese ataque
nucleofílico bien Ahora aún tendré mis
dos carbonos Unidos el uno al otro así y
el halógeno de arriba se ha pasado al
carbono de la
izquierda solía tener dos pares libres
de electrones tomó los electrones en
magenta y así es como se vería el
carbono en la
izquierda el carbono en la derecha Aún
está unido a otros dos átomos y el anón
aluro tuvo que añadirse desde abajo por
lo que ahora tendremos este halógeno
aquí abajo así y ahora entendemos por
qué es una adición anti de mis dos
átomos de
halógeno continuemos haciendo una
reacción empezaremos con el ciclo heano
como nuestro
reactivo haremos reaccionar el
cicloexano con bromo
br2 ahora si pienso en el primer paso de
mi mecanismo sé que formaré un ion alon
cíclico dibujaré ese
anillo y mostraré la forma
de mi ion al onio cíclico es llamado ion
bromonio bien formaré un anillo como
este y el bromo tendrá dos pares libres
de
electrones tendrá una carga formal de +
un así y también s que para mi mecanismo
formaré un aomb muro al mismo tiempo
tendré un anión bromuro cargado
negativamente
Así cuando pienso en dónde atacará ese
anión bromuro sí que atacará uno de
estos dos carbonos de
aquí podría atacar el de la izquierda
podría atacar el de la
derecha continuemos empezando con el
carbono en la derecha y dibujando el
producto si un par libre de electrones
de la Neón bromuro ataca este carbono de
aquí eso mandará estos electrones al
bromo y podemos continuar dibujando los
resultados de eso tendría un
anillo y el bromo de arriba se irá al
carbono en la
izquierda
así y el anión bromuro se ha añadido por
abajo del plano del
anillo
así ese es un posible producto el anón
bromuro podría atacar también el I
bromonio del lado izquierdo este par
libre de electrones podría atacar este
carbono el cual mandaría a estos
electrones al bromo Y entonces podríamos
continuar dibujando el resultado de
ataque
nucleofílico en este caso el bromo de
arriba se irá al carbono de la
derecha y tomará un par de electrones
extra y el anión bromuro nuevamente
añadido por abajo del plano del anillo
así Ahora estas dos moléculas son de
hecho moléculas
diferentes continuemos dibujando para
que sea más fácil de ver y vamos a mirar
hacia abajo desde aquí a la molécula Y
esta es la parte de arriba de tu cabeza
continuemos dibujando otra vez esa
molécula Esta es la misma
molécula viéndola desde
arriba este carbono de aquí sería este
carbono y podría ver que hay un bromo
saliendo hacia mí en el espacio pondré
un
saliendo hacia mí en el espacio en ese
carbono Y sigo con este carbono de aquí
es este carbono debería haber un bromo
alejándose de mí en el espacio en ese
carbono Ese es mi posible producto a la
derecha hacemos lo mismo bien pondremos
nuestro ojo
aquí y veremos hacia abajo Esta es la
parte de arriba puedo ver este carbono
primero puedo ver que hay un
bromo abajo en ese carbono continúo
dibujando mi anillo cicloexano Y en este
carbono hay un bromo abajo y por
supuesto en este carbono de aquí hay un
bromo saliendo hacia mí represento eso
con una cuña Y estos son mis productos
bien y si ya has estudiado
estereoquímica sabes que estos dos
productos son
e
Nan
teos el uno del otro De hecho son
moléculas diferentes que son imágenes
espejo no superponibles podemos ver que
las configuraciones absolutas se han
invertido si pienso en este carbono de
aquí el bromo saliendo hacia mí el bromo
alejándose de mí y este aquí abajo el
bromo alejándose de mí y para este un
bromo saliendo hacia mí esa es la
reacción de
halogenación